Hi, I'm Dave from the BIRT Standard Development team and today I'm going to talk a little bit
about GraphQL introspection in BIRT Suite Crawler. GraphQL APIs are becoming more popular and like
any evolving technology, BIRT Crawler has to continually improve its understanding of them.
Like any traffic that happens while crawling, anything that the application performs is
automatically captured by BIRT Suite Crawler. However, there may be functions that are possible
using the GraphQL API that aren't already performed by the application. This is where introspection
comes in. An introspection query is a way of asking a GraphQL API to describe its schema
so that we can find if there are more operations available via the API that have not yet been
performed by the application. So to demonstrate this, I'm going to use one of Portsberger's free
web security labs that allows us to use a GraphQL API to access a private post that we're not supposed
to have access to. So let's jump into BIRT Suite. Over here in the Ports browser, I have the Academy
lab open and as soon as we load the page with the network tab, we can see that there is a request to
something that looks like a GraphQL API. It's got GraphQL in the name and so that looks pretty, pretty likely to be
a GraphQL API to us. So if we run a crawl of this lab and just let that go, what will happen is that as we
reach the end of the crawl, we will start identifying potential GraphQL operations that we can perform on the lab.
So just let the crawl run through for a second.
There we go. Cool. So as you can see from the crawl pass view,
Burp Suite has automatically realized that there was GraphQL traffic naturally occurring during the crawl
and it has performed an introspection query to try and get the GraphQL API to identify its functions.
It has identified two functions, the first being get blog posts and the second being get all blog posts.
And you can see that the crawler has automatically sent a request to try and exercise those GraphQL functions.
From the second response that we have here, we can see that the get all blog posts returned us a list with
IDs 5, 4, 1 and 2. But interestingly, blog post number 3 is missing.
So if we take the request for blog post 3 and send that off to repeater and replace
the automatically generated value that Burp Crawler came up with, with number 3,
we can immediately see that we can access a blog post that wasn't listed by the API.
And if we take this password that was given to us in the response and submit that as the solution for the lab,
we can see that we've solved the lab.
So this is a really useful way of using Burp Crawler to identify operations that might not immediately be
apparent when using an application, but could result in some new attack surface and potentially reveal some bugs.
We're actively looking at ways to improve the tooling for GraphQL support in Burp Suite.
But for now, give it a try and let us know if you have any feedback.
So this is a really useful way of using Burp Crawler.